nous sommes dans l'un des hauts lieux du
beaujolais à clochemerle justement
célèbre officiellement dénommée vaut en
beaujolais le village
un parmi tant d'autres
beaujolais-villages amoureux de son vin
et de ses traditions étaient hier en
fête à l'occasion de la naissance d'une
nouvelle confrérie la confrérie du
gosier sec afin d'apporter à ce bourg
pittoresque une 9 et un cachet
véritablement typique on a apposé sur la
façade de chaque boutique une enseigne
vieux style du un artisan serrurier de
la région on saigne fort jolie en vérité
si le vendeur réjouit le coeur de
l'homme il donne vous n'en doutez pas de
l'imagination et de l'esprit aussi
laissez moi vous préciser que gosier sec
dont les statuts furent régulièrement
déposés signifie exactement groupement
des organisations sociales
intellectuelles éducatives récréatives
sportives et culturelles
ouf
et selon le rituel bachique traditionnel
de très nombreuses personnalités furent
intronisés notamment monsieur mauguin
préfet du beaujolais
à quand maintenant la confrérie des
gosiers humide